yeah so we have this from texas
scorecard
texas gop executive committee votes to
delete gab account how did your state
republican executive committee members
vote so this shows i guess everyone how
all these individuals voted they say
during their quarterly meeting in laredo
this past weekend the state republican
executive committee voted 35-25 to
delete the texas gop's gab account after
much debate
consisting of one man and one woman from
each of the state's 31 districts the
srec is essentially the governing body
of the republican party they go and say
gab is an alternative social media
platform and uh
wow
that's very stupid but yeah on the one
hand that's a black pill because the
party that's supposed to be
anti-censorship uh and you know
anti-smears of bigotry and racism and
anti-semitism things like that is doing
stupid things like this but on the other
hand you know you look at this this is
the executive committee of the gop party
in texas it's not that hard to influence
that if you get involved at the local
level at the local precinct level and
send delegates to the gop convention uh
and you know make legislative
suggestions which anyone can do if you
remember with a party there so you know
if more people did that this would be a
lot harder to do it feels like
not just with these stories of a bunch
of other stories i've you know we've
been hearing about through the past
months
the system is just rotten to its core
and i don't see how we pull out of this
uh this tailspin the foundation is
cracking
the it's it's it's like a building you
know and the wood is rotten and the
foundations are crumbling and people are
trying to come in and try and hold the
building up but it's going down man
i don't i don't know look people can be
fairly optimistic but you take a look at
what's going on with antifa getting
released you know they commit felonies
and they're free to go a woman you know
sells coffee and then she gets arrested
big tech keeps doing this the republican
party is so pathetic
and so weak
that they've known about this problem
for years and just sit there going
i don't know i think anybody that hides
behind a political party is pathetic and
weak but what what do you do start your
own party you don't need a party sure
sure
but that's right regardless the
foundation is broken because there's too
many people who are like i have to vote
republican otherwise a democrat will win
when you say the foundation is busted
and you the allegory of the building
falling down what is it what is the
found what is it the system that you're
talking about like
literally capitalism our country the
united states the function of government
and business is rotten to its core
specifically just the united states i
mean other countries have other problems
i don't live in those other countries i
live in the united states so i can talk
to you about the u.s i think other
countries have problems the uk
they got it way worse that country is on
fire i know yeah a lot of countries
arrested a guy for making a youtube
video with his with his girlfriend's dog
man those people are nuts but we got
that stuff happening here too to to a
certain degree a guy getting arrested
for posting lap for for posting rap
lyrics so those rap lyrics were threats
of terrorism it happens there was that
ricky vaughn case as well a guy getting
arrested for posting memes in 2016. yeah
that's interesting because which was
copied by a left-winger who was not
arrested the meme was like giving false
information on how to vote or something
yeah but then i left from committee
doing the exact same thing imitating
this and you know she's just fine right
right
yep she made a video i think saying the
same thing
yeah well this so so the justice system
is completely at the at the whims of the
extremists
you look at the chauvin trial you so
this is this is amazing
in the chauvin trial you have uh this
juror who lied said he didn't go to
these protests he did the floyd family
spoke there then he claimed he doesn't
remember owning that george floyd shirt
and then jack bosobic not only found a
picture of him wearing it but found a
video of him in his own youtube channel
wearing the shirt
this guy's clearly lying and you know
what's gonna happen nothing
there's not gonna be a new trial the
system is rotten to its core mark
zuckerberg can do whatever he wants they
call him in over and over and over again
nothing happens
they're just it's a pressure relief
valve the system is is is corrupt
there's democrats extracting all they
can from the system as it burns to the
ground and republicans are just also
essentially getting it as much as they
can out of it while it burns to the
ground and just telling you they're
giving you enough to make you think
they're fighting back when they are not
um the what was the 1600
checks they sent everyone that are worth
sorry what were you going to say
i was just going to say
not all republicans senator bill hagerty
the the senator the new senator from
tennessee has introduced a a big tech
bill that's actually good that uh you
know you know what i i sure not all
republicans um i like rand paul you know
we we we're we're going to praise the
ron paul ron paul is a good dude rand
paul is pretty good uh they're not all
perfect
i like this thing about common cares but
let me tell you man when the republicans
had the power they did nothing well they
actually sided with russiagate that was
in part because they weren't uh feeling
the pressure from the base when they
feel the pressure they actually they
actually flipped pretty quickly i saw
this firsthand during the uh the
confirmation of nathan simonton at the
fcc uh this was this was a guy who i
knew personally was you know not bought
by special interests who was opposed to
tech censorship who worked on efforts
against tech censorship uh but
republican senators they wanted an
establishment guy there so they were
wavering you know if it was left up to
republican senators they wouldn't have
let this guy through but uh you know
at breitbart used it you know article
after article putting the spotlight on
each republican senator that was
wavering and like within you know days
of doing that the senators all flip and
said oh yes of course we'll support
trump's nomination to the fcc it is
possible to uh to accomplish change
through the system but only if you like
keep the spotlight on these people like
24 7.
it's it's possible that because the the
traditional liberals have gone to sleep
now that the democrats have taken
everything come 2022 conservatives and
disaffected liberals moderates the
anti-woke are in full offensive and the
libs have gone to sleep thinking they've
won so maybe in 2022 the republicans
gained back the house maybe they'll get
back the senate maybe in 2024 they can
get back the presidency but i gotta say
i'm not confident that even if they do
they'll do anything
they're that look
uh
people like ted cruz you know i think
he's better than most of them but i
still think
all of them are more worried about what
the new york times thinks of them than
what their their constituents do that's
true republicans need to start ignoring
the media this needs to be the new
paradigm well everyone like with a with
a platform or in a position of influence
just ignore the media absolutely stop
participating in their broken systems
peop these republicans are probably
sitting there thinking
well if i actually do the right thing
they'll lie about me and then i'll lose
[ __ ] that people won't want to donate to
me and corporations will get scared so i
better just toe the line for what the
media says and thus the media dictates
what republicans do the republicans do
just enough to make it seem like they're
doing something and they do nothing so
what happens when the republicans
actually win back these seats
then all of a sudden you're going to see
them say well hold on we need to have a
hearing and slow down we can't just do
this democrats on the other hand are
like rubber stamp at all so the place on
fire they're getting paid massive
amounts of money to sit there and just
field questions and talk about stuff
they're getting paid
they don't barely do anything and then
they're getting bribed by corporations
to pass bills and to vote yes on stuff
they haven't read
so busted they should how many how how
how how many times how many elections
are we supposed to go through crossing
our fingers
right i think one of the issues too is
that
millennials have only have only
experienced so many election cycles
and so as the older generation starts to
fade out and retire and stop paying
attention or pass on
then you end up with the next generation
of you know gen xers and millennials who
are
just basing everything off of
we've been through four election cycles
and we've seen this that and this this
is the time this is our chance if you
took one person who was a thousand years
old he'd be like oh yeah this again
we've we've gone back and forth with
this like hundreds of times yeah you're
not gonna get what you want the system
is a is a gross amalgam of weird corrupt
policies that don't make sense half the
time
they'll also be like don't break your
country
don't break your country just come on
guys it's up to you no it's it's it's
broken well they're breaking it there's
people broken setting fires i know for
for over a year the riots have been
continuing
and then we get the fbi being like these
domestic these far-right terrorists are
the biggest threat and you're like i i
didn't have i didn't hear helicopters
and sirens outside my house because of
the far right
i didn't have to move an event i was
putting on near my home with with guest
speakers because of the far right the
far right was the terror it was the
boogeyman terrorist it was because
antifa called and threatened to burn the
theater down yeah it was because far
left riders crossed the bridge and
started rioting in the suburbs yet i
turn on the tv and you the system is
dominated by the cult
these people who don't care you know and
i really believe a lot of these people
go on tv these like you know chris ray
or whatever the fbi they know they're
lying of course they do but they don't
care about you and they don't all they
care about is making sure the new york
times is nice to them they're all more
worried about what the new york times
has to say than the people of this
country there was a soldier nipsen quote
about this during the soviet union uh
something like uh we know they're lying
they know that we know that they that
they
they know that we know that they're
lying and we know that they know
that we know
that they're that they know
that that's what it's getting to that's
the point we're getting to there's a lot
of traditional liberals who don't know
anything
and it's the best example is that
they've all gone to sleep they're no
longer paying attention to politics the
ratings are dropping they don't care
they never cared
and it's scary that these people are
empowering sociopaths and psychopaths
and that's true for republicans too
there's a lot of conservatives who go to
sleep all the same don't pay attention
and that's why you end up with a lot of
never trumper conservatives who just all
they cared for was the establishment so
i end up with with kenzinger and
illinois getting all this support and
getting these votes
because you've got people who just don't
care dude
i think they're on the way out i think
liz cheney's on her way out she might
lose her leadership position kim zing is
going to be redistricted out there and
he'll probably get like a position on
msnbc as a comment as a ex-republican
commentator very popular uh but they're
they seem they do at the moment they
seem to be on their way out of the party
except for like you know the really
smart ones like dan crenshaw who like
you know pretend to be all maggot but
are basically just establishment yeah
but they have it's interesting that they
have to pretend to be magic
right because i think that there's a lot
of people who are uh who woke up due to
the internet they're paying attention
now they're getting their facts they're
watching shows like this and they're
realizing you know the media is lying a
lot
but the media is doing everything in its
power to make sure they can maintain the
facade so one thing that's got to happen
is youtube's gotta gotta purge itself
youtube wants to be netflix they don't
wanna be youtube anymore let me ask you
a question what's let's about everyone a
question what's worse big media or big
tech
big tech yeah tech what would you say i
would say big media why why would you
guys say because big tech can block you
from talking your own mother correct but
what drives that i think big media has
driven most of the tech censorship uh
because
you see this happen like whenever
facebook or youtube doesn't move quickly
enough i'm not saying you know the tech
companies are blameless but whenever
they are they don't move quickly enough
uh they'll start up these huge
advertiser boy because they're against
youtube against facebook
and the whole panic around
disinformation and fake news was started
by the media
right but if that hadn't happened that
there would have been some pressure on
the tech companies to censor but it's
only because of the relentless pressure
from the media over the past uh four or
five years that this has escalated so
rapidly the hunter biden story was
censored by big tech before there's any
media
there were some tweets from journalists
well i think it's gone to the point now
that they're anticipating what the media
will do and what the democrats will do
the reason i said tech is because they
can build the algorithms that you don't
see and that like with media at least
you see what they're feeding you and
other people are eating it
maybe you're not but at least you see it
that that's what they're eating but with
tech
algorithms you don't know like why am i
seeing the things i think i like i don't
know because some some scientist in a
room with decided that he wants me to
see it that way and i can never know
because the proprietary i think i think
over time youtube is going to slowly
excise channels like this
they are doing everything in their power
to make it seem like that well they're
not they're not banning or censoring you
but they will reduce visibility
slowly over time go open a private over
open open a private window in a browser
and then go to youtube.com and you'll be
like wow is this what people are
watching yes because it's the only thing
they know it's the only thing they know
that exists because it's what youtube
gives them
open up a new account on spotify see
here's the music they're recommending to
people
we are we are in this small space
of
i guess i don't know what you'd call it
right um
initiated individuals i guess the one we
described people who have paid attention
to politics who know what's going on and
they're doing everything their power to
make sure that more people don't come
into the space and just go back to sleep
everything's okay we're going to keep
blowing up kids in the middle east don't
ask any questions take the blue pill
absolutely
had weapons of mass destruction
actually he didn't but they told us that
for years and that allowed us to invade
iraq
and station troops and murder how many
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of civilians lots of civilians
how many people have died
hundreds of thousands
this is the same companies that are
giving us the lies now about the far
this and the farther than the extremist
this and the color of that guy's skin
and you know what the bet you know the
best thing about all of it is
in 50 years
if they if they win
no one will ever talk about this
conversation ever no one will remember
yeah it'll be it'll be in the history
books it won't be in the history books
it'll be purged it'll be excised from
the from the uh the great libraries of
the the of the digital cloud
and uh it'll never have happened
as soon as these generate the generation
that we're in passes
if they have their way and it sounds
like nothing's going to stop them
because the republican party is a bunch
of feckless losers then we end up in 50
years with the republican party as a
bunch of socialist other kin arguing
with communist transhumanists who
have already integrated their you know
bodies into robot bodies and
i made this joke on twitter but it's not
even it's it's not meant to be a joke as
it's it's the truth
in 15 years you're gonna have a young
republican being like everybody knows
that socialism is good but these
communists are too far left
that's the way it's been going you can
see it happening absolutely you could
you you just need only look back a
little bit to the 90s look back to the
2000s when bernie sanders is like we
need a border barrier
hillary clinton carrie all these people
like bill to build the wall
then trump's like okay build the wall
how dare you you're far right open
borders now
the the people who used to protest the
the world trade organization that's
hilarious the battle the battle for
seattle or whatever the battle in
seattle remember that
late night i think was late 90s huge
world trade organization protest it was
the left saying no to this big free
trade internationalist policy
now they're for open borders the
oligarchy co-opted their own uh their
own opponents uh actually an interesting
article by uh angelo cody villa former
senator
uh
he's out the claremont institute
and i'm sort of arguing it's myself
because i said you know it's big media
worse than big tech but what this
article argues is that they're all
interchangeable like the guy who runs
the fbi the guy who runs facebook the
democrat politician the democrat
president
all of the the guy who runs cnn all of
them are interchangeable elites working
towards the same girl the guy who runs
the activist organization also
interchangeable they trade places and
they all want the same thing which is to
reduce the power of the people and
increase the power of elites thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time